so here's a simple example of how you
can control your confidence in less than
20 seconds go look in your past at times
when you weren't sure if you go through
but you made it happen when you thought
you wanted the girl and you got the girl
or you got the guy you got the job and
so to generate massive amounts of
confidence you almost have to
bulletproof yourself so nothing toxic
nothing distracting no interruptions
can get in wanna be happy build a life
not just the business
[Music]
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn three simple tricks you
can use to build your confidence
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with trick number
one change your behavior with repeat
safety there are some people around us
who just seem like they are born with
natural confidence you know who I'm
talking about
they're super smooth super confident
they always know the right thing to say
think about President Obama it just
seems like a smooth guy think of one of
his famous yes we can rally speeches not
being political here just talking about
his oratorical skills what do you notice
about how he speaks he's powerful he's
decisive he speaks slowly and almost
never stumbles or stutters his points
are clear and they're to the point he's
the epitome of confidence when it comes
to a speaker on stage so when you look
at somebody like him it's very easy to
assume that he has some innate ability
that he was born with either you have it
or you don't
but the truth is confidence is a skill
and President Obama just like all
confident people built that skill he
practiced it over a lifetime so here's a
simple example of how you can control
your confidence in less than 20 seconds
take something you routinely say like
what you did this weekend and change the
way you say I want you to channel your
inner super confident person it could be
Barack Obama
it could be Susan Sarandon it could be
whoever you want don't focus on who it
is don't even worry about what you say
instead focus on changing how you say it
sit up straight speak slowly and imagine
what you're saying is incredibly
important because the people listening
want to hear it
let me show you an example a little
before-and-after yeah I can't even
remember I mean I think it was pretty
good it was actually pretty crazy but I
just went to a movie and saw some
friends you know the usual I guess now
let's compare the after we had a great
weekend I was with the kids on Saturday
then Michelle and I caught a Broadway
show and finished the night at that new
sake bar downtown
now would you notice notice first that
I'm intentionally using someone else to
roleplay this really lets us get into
play-acting without worrying about our
own life our own Saturday ooh maybe I
don't have as cool the life as going to
a sake bar don't worry about that all
we're doing here is working on our
delivery remember nobody sees inside of
you they don't see how confident you are
how much work you spent practicing all
they see is the way you answer a
question or the way you sit when you're
talking to them so when it comes to
confidence confidence can actually come
from the outside in not just from the
inside out which is what everybody tells
you so instead of waiting for it to just
magically appear where's my confidence
where is it we're actually changing our
behavior something everyone can do and
we're letting the confidence follow the
external influences the internal and
once you master this concept you can
apply it to a lot more than just how you
speak and how you sit trick number two
rob confidence from the past with Dean
grad coz I want you to borrow confidence
from the past
you see when we're doing something where
we have to muster up the confidence we
think of the things that could go wrong
we think of what if I don't come through
what if I don't say the right things I
need to rehearse this over and over what
if what if what if what if we change
that and instead of thinking about what
could go wrong of course we know this
start thinking about what can go right
but better yet rob confidence from the
go look in your past at times when you
weren't sure if you go through but you
made it happen when you thought you
wanted the girl and you got the girl or
you got the guy you got the job you got
the deal you got the money you got the
sale a type or you you you scored the
touchdown you got the run you we're good
at band you you were the star of the
play rob confidence from the past remind
your body remind yourselves remind your
subconscious what it felt like and bring
it into the present time I'm telling you
you can transcend that old confidence
into your current state and watch your
change your state of mind change just
like that also if you want to learn how
to build more confidence check out my
250 for confidence series it's free the
link in the description below one of the
real reasons we don't do the things that
frighten us is because we are afraid of
being judged and trick number three the
last one before very special bonus clip
is bulletproof your tee btf the third
method that changemakers use to generate
great levels of confidence they
bulletproof their TBT f-type bubble of
total focus in previous podcasts I've
encouraged you to build a tight bubble
of total focus around yourself in this
age of dramatic distraction you can be
distracted you can do iconic work you
just don't get to do both and so the
most productive people on the planet the
people with the greatest impact in the
world
they all have this metaphorical type
bubble of total focus that they build
around their mindsets their heart sets
and their work routines and so to
generate massive amounts of confidence
you almost have to bulletproof yourself
so nothing toxic nothing distracting no
interruptions can get in and then what
happens is you literally start to drop
into transient hypofrontality that's the
neurobiological phenomenon that happens
when you drop into solitude and you get
out of distraction and you get into this
monomaniacal focus where you slow down
the cortisol flow which is the fear
hormone
and you increase serotonin and you
increase dopamine which is the
inspirational neurotransmitter and your
prefrontal cortex which is the seat of
reasoning and that chattering mind that
goes on all day actually gets silent for
a brief burst of time and that's why
they call it transient hypofrontality
for a short period time your prefrontal
cortex becomes really really quiet and
that drops your brain from beta waves to
alpha waves and researchers like me hide
Csikszentmihalyi call this the flow
state when you are playing basketball
and you're really in the moment in the
flow of life hours go by in minutes and
all of a sudden you find these
superhuman abilities maybe you're at
work and you're just jamming on a
project with your teammates and you're
actually having fun well again the whole
day goes by and you did your best work
that's flow and how do you get to flow
by protecting and bulletproofing your
mind set your heart set and you doing
your best work another way to
bulletproof your your mind set and this
create this tight bubble of total focus
is really understanding the importance
of reading great autobiographies
listening to great podcasts you know
turning off the news because the purpose
of the news is to frighten you you know
the news is actually not objective in
terms of the way the world is reality is
so much better there it's so much more
positive there are heroes on the planet
there are so many kind people out there
there are so many people building
remarkably awesome businesses there are
so many people scaling great nonprofits
there are so many people out there in
your own community living these great
lives in their own unique way but the
news doesn't report that it's one
negative story after another because the
purpose of the news is to frighten you
and if they frighten you they're going
to addiction one way to really generate
great confidence is to build this type
bubble of total focus around you and
another way to do that
is to clean out the toxicity in your
life stop watching news start reading
great autobiographies so you understand
you know you will have your Robben
Island moment or season or year or maybe
even a decade I mean rah Nelson Mandela
I was fortunate enough to be in his
prison cell last month and I learned he
was on Robben Island for 18 years his
total period of confinement was 27 years
and again he could have seen that as
failure he used it as fuel now I've got
a special bonus clip on how to change
your beliefs from a recipe you thought I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions time to go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one what is the
belief that you want to change number
two how can you change your behavior to
change your belief and number three
where can you Rob confidence from the
past how do you help somebody become
more confident well you know I always
look at babies having had one myself a
babies are born
with so much confidence if you push the
prandtl it'll come people come and go
your baby's so cute they don't go don't
look at me I don't like attention they
love attention have you sat around a
pool you'll heal these causing daddy
look at the mummy look at me so we come
into the world loving attention I mean
that's the first experience you everyone
looks at you the doctor the nurse or
Midwife parents grandparents so what I
tend to do is is reactivate that in a
confidence that you were born with and
at the same time have a look at why
you've lost your confidence it's always
there will be something very specific
that causes people to lose their
confidence but they don't really lose it
I believe it becomes submerged under all
kinds of negative beliefs when you
remove them the confidence can come back
so I give people back what they were
born with which is better because then
they don't go away into think oh I've
never had it they go anything yeah of
course I had it and I can have it back
again can anybody become well confident
yeah absolutely you think with your mind
is and the mind is really simple your
mind does what it absolutely thinks you
want it to do so if you fear rejection
if you've been human
a turd at school or by you knows one of
my clients was telling me that she went
she went to work on her first day her
boss shouted out across the floor she's
useless she'll never be good at anything
and when you're humiliated like that
the number-one job of your mind is to
make sure you never experience that
again cm ID is always working to move
you away from anything that causes you
pain and it has to find out what causes
you pain to move you away from it so
people who've been rejected then spend
their life avoiding rejection avoiding
humiliation and they won't put
themselves forwards but when you take
that away and show them that you can't
be rejected the only person who can
truly reject you as you somebody cannot
give you a job and not like you they
can't really reject you because they
don't really know you and then and so I
teach people that there's no such thing
as rejection nobody can diminish you and
once you believe in yourself then it
doesn't really matter what the people
think and people get very conservative
as arrogance but it's not it's just a
self-esteem that radiates out from you
so you can't really read a minute you
can have bad days but we can all feel
incredibly confident and incredibly
self-assured and the great thing is that
people love that you want to be with
people who are self-assured
if you want to learn how to develop more
confidence check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there confidence confidence confidence
confidence confidence confidence
confident